[Musique]
je me pose toujours des milliards de
questions
mes amis peuvent en témoigner d'air
comment est-ce qu'on passe d'un pépin à
un pommier
par exemple comment fait un caméléon
pour se camoufler
parce que nous savons tous que ça peut
changer de couleur mais comment quel
mécanisme
comment est-ce qu'ils s'adaptent et puis
les conférences ted alors pourquoi on
est toujours sur ce tapis rond et rouge
vous êtes jamais demandé c'est normal de
se poser autant de questions parce que
la curiosité est un trait de caractère
naturel acquis depuis notre plus jeune
âge de tout temps et de toutes les
époques
elle est définie comme le désir de
savoir le désir de connaître une réalité
qui nous est encore inconnue mais que
nous pressentons alors porté par la soif
de comprendre le monde nous homo sapiens
sommes devenus des explorateurs des
explorateurs de cette réalité que nous
ne connaissons pas encore alors à
l'époque des grands explorateurs tels
que christophe colomb magellan il
s'agissait de cartographier la planète
découvrir de nouveaux territoires ou
encore de nouvelles richesses mais au
siècle des lumières
le rapport à l'exploration le voyage
change
il s'agit de comprendre les autres
espèces sur la planète alors de grands
noms tels que charles darwin à bord de
leurs navires vont parcourir le globe
pour comprendre les autres espèces ils
vont alors analysé observé décrire
dessinée classifier le vivant à l'aide
de ces magnifiques planches naturaliste
l'homme se fascine alors pour les autres
espèces il veut comprendre leur
fonctionnement leur diversité et leur
répartition sur le globe
par exemple ils vont explorer terre air
mer
aujourd'hui à l'ère des grands
bouleversements climatiques montée des
eaux
sécheresse perte de la biodiversité
pollution le rapport à l'exploration
prend encore une autre tournure
humblement nous venons questionner le
vivant elle ce qu'ils peuvent nous
apprendre pour notre propre survie
comment allons-nous vivre en harmonie
sur cette planète avec les autres
espèces tout en utilisant ou plutôt en
utilisant de manière responsable les
ressources de notre belle planète
comment allons-nous habiter tous
ensemble tout en préservant l'eau l'air
les seuls cette approche s'appelle le
biomimétisme bio la vie
mimétisme imiter illimitée la vie est
une approche créative qui consiste à
s'inspirer du fonctionnement du vivant
allez comprendre ces principes pour
répondre à nos grands enjeux de société
que ce soit des enjeux sociétaux et
environnementaux ou économiques
alors sans surprise durant mes études
d'architecte ingénieur j'ai continué à
me poser encore beaucoup de questions et
en particulier comment en tant que futur
praticienne j'allais répondre à ces
grands enjeux de société
en 2009 je découvre le biomimétisme et
en pour moi c'était une réponse globale
une réponse évidente pour répondre à un
problème très complexe et en 2015
je m'envole pour une année de tour du
monde à la rencontre de ces architectes
ces biologistes ces chercheurs qui
s'inspire du liseron pour concevoir des
villes et des bâtiments durables
alors ce voyage m'a amené à vivre au
zimbabwe étudie à l'université de kyoto
au japon ou encore aux mighty à boston
et à l'université victoria en nouvelle
zélande
c'était mon premier pas dans
l'exploration du vivant et je vous livre
ici un extrait de mon carnet de voyage
voici
deux isolants donc tous deux ont la
fonction d'isoler n'a par exemple une
laine minérale et un plumage donc tous
deux idoles en captant une couche d'air
via un matériau alors les matériaux que
nous nous fabriquons une eau que ça soit
laine de roche laine de verre
polystyrène enfin en tout cas les
isolants souvent c'est des matériaux qui
sont basées sur des composants pas
forcément abondant sur terre pas
facilement recyclables ou alors qu'ils
vont demander une grande quantité
d'énergie pour être recyclables et
difficile à mettre en oeuvre dans les
méthodologies dans le vivant ce plumage
lui va être 100% recyclable basé sur des
composés abondant dans le vivant et puis
surtout va être une source d'inspiration
pour beaucoup plus que ça parce que ceux
plus mal contrairement à nous isolons
qui sont fixes les mêmes toute l'année
ce prime ce pillage a la capacité de
s'adapter à l'échelle de la journée ou à
l'échelle des saisons est-ce que vous
avez déjà vu déroule gorges des moineaux
en hiver justement vont ce conflit pour
augmenter la capacité d'isolation en
emprisonnant une plus grande couche
d'air et donc varier l'isolation à
l'échelle de la journée à l'échelle des
saisons aujourd'hui dans le monde que ce
soit en angleterre
om haïti ou encore à paris des
chercheurs se mobilisent pour étudier
les enveloppes du vivant et donc
améliorer les enveloppes de bâtiment
l'objectif est d'avoir des enveloppes
qui vont permettre une meilleure gestion
de l'énergie
moi je dis vivement les bâtiments qui
comme des plumages vaut se gonfle et se
dégonfle et pour qu'on gère mieux
l'énergie dans le bâtiment alors la
voici deux systèmes de ventilation donc
on en a produit par l'homme système
classique de ventilation électrique
et puis l'autre c'est une termitière vue
du dessus alors tous les deux
remplissent la fonction de ventiler mais
avec des propriétés et en esthétique
un peu différent la termitière à base de
cheminée de conduit 2 canaux souterrains
va permettre la ventilation toute
l'année quelles que soient les
variations climatiques
même en haut de la cheminée vous avez
une adaptation de la cheminée suivant
les vents dominants pour une meilleure
ventilation dans cette héritière et
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là c'est
encore mieux de mieux que ça parce que
les termites par leurs activités vont
enrichir les seuls stocker du carbone au
lieu d'en émettre et on peut lister
encore beaucoup de propriétés comme ça
intéressante pour nos villes et pour nos
bâtiments
alors voici un bâtiment au zimbabwe à
harare
inspiré du système de ventilation de cet
intermédiaire donc se veut ce bâtiment
est basé comme la termitière sur un
système de ventilation passif et donc
après calcul on se rend compte qu'il a
permis une économie d'énergie de 35% par
rapport à des systèmes de ventilation
classique au zimbabwe donc c'est quand
même conséquent et durant ce tour du
monde
j'ai été très ému de visiter ce bâtiment
parce que quand vous cherchez
biomimétisme en architecture vous tomber
très rapidement sur l'iss building ce
bâtiment à harare et surtout j'ai eu la
chance d'apprendre auprès de
l'architecte milk pierre ce qui
aujourd'hui à 80 ans continue de
s'inspirer du fonctionnement du vivant
et se passionner pour les écosystèmes et
ce qu'ils peuvent nous apprendre pour
concevoir des villes et des bâtiments
durables et en parlant d'écosystèmes
justement voici un écosystème forestier
est une ville nous avons beaucoup aussi
à apprendre du fonctionnement des
écosystèmes
parce qu'ils ont la capacité de
dépolluer l'air les seuls de stocker du
carbone ils peuvent aussi réguler leur
température et ça on en aurait bien
besoin surtout en ces périodes là où
nous souffrons de l'îlot de chaleur en
été alors vivement les villes
inspiré du fonctionnement des
écosystèmes et cette approche mobilise
justement des chercheurs partout dans le
monde que ce soit en nouvelle-zélande
aux états unis ou encore en europe où
une nouvelle génération de bâtiments est
en train d
hergé c'est ce qu'on appelle des
bâtiments dits régénératif inspiré des
écosystèmes qui au lieu d'avoir une
empreinte négative ou neutre vont avoir
une empreinte positive
alors bientôt on peut rêver de ville ou
de bâtiments qui par leur fonctionnement
vont venir enrichir les sols et crée une
agriculture plus saine vont venir
stocker du carbone et nous permettre de
mieux respirer et favoriser la
biodiversité dans les villes alors en
france on compte près de 200
laboratoires de recherche sur le sujet
du biomimétisme tous domaines confondus
que ce soit les material architecture
par exemple et quand je suis revenue de
ce voyage de tour du monde
j'avais très envie de contribuer à
l'émergence de cette approche parce que
on a besoin d'outils de méthode et
surtout d'un langage commun entre les
différents corps de métiers par exemple
vous prenez un architecte et un
biologiste
alors ça peut être un biologiste
spécialiste des insectes par exemple bas
pour les faire communiquer au début
c'est pas évident du tout du tout on a
vraiment besoin d'un langage commun
entre ces deux disciplines est donc de
créer des ponts entre architecture et
biologiques par exemple c'est dans cet
optique que j'ai rejoint l'équipe du cbi
hausse à paris et le muséum d'histoire
naturelle en thèse pour justement
travailler sur ces sujets là alors je
vous ai montré des espèces un peu
extraordinaire
donc on a vu les termitières on a vu un
caméléon le vivant c'est près de 9
millions d'espèces estimé aujourd'hui on
en a décrit que 20% alors autant de
belles histoires à écrire ensemble
autant de belles innovations et le
vision c'est aussi très proche de nous
dans notre quotidien
alors très peu de très près notre peau
les légumes que ce soit nos oiseaux des
villes ou encore je sais pas un escargot
qui traînent dans une salade mal lavé le
vivant est vraiment très proche de nous
alors je vous invite à relever la tête
ouvrir les yeux sortir de votre coquille
pour regarder le vivent donc à vous loue
à vos jumelles
soyez curieux de nature merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]